these really good this is the new outfit
in this easy right welcome to scramble
where I'm inviting some new friends into
my kitchen to make my favorite dish
scrambled eggs now I'm cooking with
double trouble today
they're twins in fact they're gorgeous
twins they are WWE royalty and I hear
you ladies are just as competitive as I
am is that right yeah so welcome to chez
moi congratulations thank you can you
believe it they're not twins ice we feel
like they are winning some spiritual way
how far past are you pushing so they
could be born on the same day by the way
we've already been competitive about
who's coming out first so we need to
think about breakfast yeah a little bit
help we do a healthy breakfast right so
you set the terms we're gonna do a
healthy breakfast and and what are you
dying to get from this okay so my
husband always asked me to make my fried
egg and it terrifies me I can't do it
alright that's it that's it you can do
that yes a Friday yeah he's a vegetarian
so I'm lucky eggs are like the big thing
right what about a perfect sort of
breakfast sandwich that sounds fair
otherwise I'd be outnumbered four-to-one
yeah we're real good we're bad girl can
we do yeah a tag team likes your tag
okay show me who's gonna start I feel
like I should I'm the better cook Wow
she knew no why because I am just such
an amazing entrepreneur and so I'm
always too busy so you're gonna say and
then you gonna shout tag when you want
to change over yes congratulations the
new season by the way season no more
season five i we do not think gonna turn
into what about cooking skills in a
scale of 1 to 10 where are we give me
give me an 8 I'm gonna [ __ ] I'm 7 that's
it I'll take that give me give me give
me a 6 don't think I might be a maybe a
4 you ready I mean but when I try I'm
actually really good rights is mine
years oh really because Christmas dinner
you loved it ladies ladies ladies ladies
relax otherwise we'll be having an early
pregnancy right we ready ready all right
let's start off with toasted bread
okay good I was gonna do that thinking
bread first yeah let's go so I'm gonna
put the panel on get that nice and hot
okay yeah I'm gonna skate yes this
attainted yes ladies please take it
straight there's Mike I can't get really
comfortable to handle
keep your fingers well back and there's
two nice slices down let's keep it nice
and thick so it doesn't sort of fall
apart you now take your knife and get
some butter okay and just lightly spread
that butter now the question do you
prefer keeping your butter always out
yeah definitely
yeah room temp and then take your salt I
just lightly seasoned these seasoned the
bread it's gonna come out so tasty okay
and then just drop that in there she
wanted to put water in the pan what's
what I know I didn't know I know
water down plain into shock
our guys always that competitive I mean
but even it's so tempting by the school
even sports sports we were a soccer be
here always won the award she acts like
I didn't win any she won bigger ones but
I'd like to put a little touch of butter
into the pan again they'll get the
underneath nice and crispy as well now
we're gonna use turkey bacon again not
healthier I'm gonna tag out okay check
out already right hot pan just a little
teaspoon of olive oil in there okay keep
there you go good yep get your bacon put
into the pan the base here and lay away
from you
so then splash back we get this nice and
crispy now nice take a little nip
herbicide turn that around
we've got a color on there I like my
baby just spoke out thanks mother
oh I got to ask what's that climbing
plant no we're either of us okay she
said she didn't want baby number two and
she was done and then she gets pregnant
and then two days later I get a feeling
that I need to get a pregnancy test and
take it then I'm like it's because of
her but I just got engaged like I'm not
even married
Wow and now I'm engaged and I'm having a
baby
how exciting so take them out okay
and then we're gonna do one of the most
difficult thing to get right properly
and that's trying it out so I'm getting
so hard that the secret find a great egg
is keeping it nice and slow okay well
done good so bread done we're here now
take it out take the egg okay always
crack on a flat side really important oh
really yeah so bad I'll do it on like
the edge of the pan oh yeah oh there's a
pan what happens then shall go straight
in and you'll get some shell fragmented
across the egg always on a flat surface
but slowly cook this egg the better so I
go down and lift
okay brilliant
there you go yeah I guess you are knit
first and that wasn't a tag out your
step well done now a little seasoning
touch of salt just on the egg just take
a little touch of butter put that to the
side so now that up that's it helps to
cook the egg white will keep off the
heat now and it will just continue
cooking nice and slow without splashing
everywhere so toast bacon egg we get
this thing a little bit more healthier
good get out take out can take your
avocado slice down take the end of your
knife and just go crisscross just a
little touch of lime over that was
stopping me going down they want to have
a skinny margarita see there you go
September yeah yeah they get you sleep
they get you spoon and look you've
already chopped up the avocado is all
nice and chopped check that egg out now
how do you see that butter just get over
the side okay we might crack that so
yeah see didn't I mean this she also you
one-handed in panic ladies please
Reisen can't have a match right here
finish time we have to be super quick
with this one now pan piping hot
okay so avocadoes done yep yep I'm
Carlos done Baker's done sandwiches
getting nice and crisp so good now we'll
start with the spinach chill arts in
touch of seasoning in there just a touch
good
and now we're going to just lightly
sweat them off just a touch handful of
spinach into the pan that's going to
come down dramatically okay you push it
down and put it back now you'll see all
disintegrate do that grating and then
before you take that out a tiny teaspoon
of butter just spit on fire now give it
a really nice flavor and then take that
and put that spinach onto your towel
okay okay and that will help get rid of
all that water good well done
so this competitive edge hymen is still
that through the kids because they're
going to be even more competitive know
when they see their cousins oh they're
gonna month and then they go back to the
video is the rest think you measuring Oh
read the competitive household I know
they're gonna probably be a tag team
pleased to take that now when you've got
me all that water have a little taste
know my name for the hot sriracha I like
you guys seriously who is the biggest
diva truthfully oh I knew you were gonna
point it mean who's wearing leopard
doesn't that tell you something yeah why
are you the biggest why you're the
biggest does that go back saying that
because she thinks I'm bougie yeah I am
not a diva I enjoy the finer things in
life
what and I don't think that's a bad
thing right now for the most important
part is sending on this thing okay this
is the beauty where we sort of put this
beautiful thing together cuz you'll do
that I feel like I should yes
you ready get the largest slice of bread
first okay down and then we're just
going to put a nice tablespoon of your
spicy mayo on your spinach lay on top
generous copious amounts of spinach okay
and just drop that avocado
on top of that spinach okay take your
bacon and roll that turkey bacon
go for like three on there nice and flat
lift your egg take it out yeah and then
on finish with the egg and then let show
want some of that butter and olive oil
around the plate dip into and then
finally sit there with your beautiful
so did your kids love did you cook like
a lot or literally every weekend and I
bought an animal of it
I bought them pigs and sheep so they
nurtured them and understood where food
comes from what the ladies now we have
to keep this tasting neutral okay
because we don't be unfair do we the
crew you guys I mean yet have you okay
why don't they taste this okay
lift it up will you see that big bang
take a big bite yeah that's how you eat
the breakfast it's perfectly seasoned
the toast maybe a little bit more to the
cinema soggy bottom you may have a soggy
bottom there look pretty
i'ma go it's really nicely toasted
yeah there you go
what's your fingers did it was perfectly
seasoned the egg was cooked perfectly
the toast for me was better than
Gordon's but if I was to ward my
favorite I have to be happy Gordon's
Jesus 20:27 champion in fact that we did
just meet one minute I'll be back this
is something didn't quite feel Rabi back
in one minute
oh sorry you know I think we can make
this look a little different this remake
you look more like su no sir
please you know big THANK YOU to brie
and Nikki thank you so much would be
incredible guess and don't forget to
check out total Bella's on a congrats
ladies well that's it for scrambled now
please leave a comment below on who you
think won the cook-off and don't forget
to subscribe to get more fun videos like
this one
you